Hey guys,
Tim Ferris going to show just a few moves that are surprisingly easy to do,
but very impressive looking in the world of Aqua Yoga.
And I'm no expert experts or people like Kipling here at Kipling, k, p, l, I,
N, n, and all the socials, Jason Nemer, uh, Jenny, of course, those are the,
the co founders of Yoga and many others are the pros.
But that's why I'm showing you this because these do not require you to be a
pro. All right? So the first is going to be a walkover to throne.
So this is something that people have a lot of trepidation about getting into a
handstand. Uh, so Kipling can feel free to add some color as needed,
but I'm going to show you what is actually an entrance into a routine of any
type that is surprisingly easy to do. So we'll show it and then
I can sort of add some thoughts.
First thing you'll notice is that I'm not like this getting ready for it because
it looks terrible. All right? And you learn these things over time.
All I'm going to do is sort of be sitting like this,
then my legs are going to straddle pike up to here. Right?
That's what it's going to look like. And we'll, we'll show it. It looks like.
Okay. All right. And then we're in throwing,
then we can do fun stuff like pop the bird.
Okay. Okay. No, that's not the part we're going to cover.
We're just going to cover the walk over. So let's come down. All right,
so with the walkover,
what I want to point out is that I'm actually aiming to land right about here,
right? If you go right from the glute, when she actually sits,
your foot's going to slip.
So you're kind of aiming right here in terms of the mail or not necessarily mail
, but base portion of it. Um, Kipling. Any thoughts on the actual hand? Stan?
Any pointers? Their hands close to the hips as you are better.
Okay. Slowly.
So the flier should have their hands close to my hips.
You don't wanna be too far out,
obviously better to be a little too close than too far away. And, uh,
in general,
a lot of folks when they're thinking of hand stands their different ways to do
it.
Start with shoulder with then you can either have your middle fingers pointing
forward or index fingers pointing forward. You can play with what works for you,
uh,
and getting a little bit of extension can help quite a bit with slowing things
down. She's actually kind of a fun drill. You can do hand stands against a wall.
Start off, kick up and then really push,
push to get that extension and brake. It'll slow you down.
So let's show it one more time and then we will do a few more.
Okay?
Okay, so you see them right here.
Now what I'm going to do is Hook on top of the feet.
She's going to Dorse a flex, pull her toes back and then just sit right up.
Boom. Now from here, since this looks kind of weird, you can,
you put the feet right on the shins and that allows you to do all sorts of
things. You actually rest pretty easily from here.
And then at a later point in time,
I can do something like this, which is just the one to
catch into Burton. You know, that's when I catch my feet are pointed out.
There are many different ways to do this.
I find that to be the least violent against my flyer,
lots of bend and then kind of popping up and then placing the feet back to
parallel,
almost like an Olympic weightlifter coming up from a clean and like popping it
up to get their hands into proper position.
Very similar and I would suggest staying away from the pop to bird for now.
But if you're at a level where that makes sense,
placing a lot of weight on the hands, uh,
and allows the flyer if they have good body awareness to kind of break
themselves on the way down. So it's not just a uncontrolled freefall. Okay.
And that is the walkover to throne to Burke.
Thanks for watching everybody.
I would love to share more videos with you if you would like to see them.
Please subscribe right here and I will get to making more for you.